because that
so today I will present a some our
recent work in these so-called ice
empirical analysis this is a word we we
made up so later on I will tell you what
what what do you really mean okay so so
let's first take a look at the merchant
learning paradigm of data analysis so I
use these I wrote we indicated this is
the sample size okay inversion learning
paradigm so essentially for the
empirical measures we can start with the
objective functional feature selection
and then optimize for the objective
function and then eventually we can
validate the results because the
merchant learning area comes when they
are already very large and then so a lot
of emphasis is on the computation so
computation typically is another big
deal in this paradigm and by the
theoretical analysis it's quite
interesting is most of the theoretical
analysis to rely on these so-called
analyzing tactical analysis for example
the concentration in ecology is one of
the popular use for these areas and then
the nice thing of these and nice
Antarctic analysis is that the a lot of
things is very straight forward look at
for example the sample calculation is
studies typically it's a kind of a
difficult problem but in this case it's
really straightforward because you in
concentrating quality in particular
proceeding the result and then you can
straight forward to calculate or what
sample size you need okay so I call this
paradigm as a parallel paradigm in the
sense that the empirical methods provide
evidence for theoretical analysis the
theoretical analyses apply the guidance
for the empirical analysis and then
these two measures are cobbled together
very tightly together in this case the
in contrast the classical aesthetic or
paradigm is quite different because the
statistic high
long history the classic analysis
typically our deal with the small or
moderate size of data and we have
empirical measures we still do model
building select model selection model
fitting and the eventually we made a
universe okay and but our asymptotic
analysis it's quite different is
theoretical analysis based on these
asymptotic analysis as in thousand
actresses eyes name suggests is a full
large sample and then we have typically
have a consistency of the results and
the isotopic distribution of our
estimator and so on so forth so in this
sense this paradigm is not like a
parallel paradigm but rather like a
serial paradigm in the sense that our
theoretical analysis is extrapolate the
empirical matter in parameter we get the
results for real data we kind of we
interpolate the real data but identical
analysis or theoretical analysis
extrapolate this result to hypothetical
large sample okay
and then these two analysis is
complementary with each other okay and
now we are facing another big issue is
that no we all have a large data of big
data okay and then our empirical matter
because was mostly invented in the old
days and then the computation is really
a bottleneck and a lot of issues with
our empirical matter however the
asymptotic analysis the developing
instances community really fits very
well in this paradigm because always
sample sizes really now it's a very very
large ok so then the question naturally
can ask is is that these asymptotic
matches can help to it's also easier for
computation or easy in empirical methods
okay actually even in the old days and
our asymptotic analysis helped us do a
lot of empirical methods for example
most of
the statistical inference based on
asymptotic analysis for example the
confidence interval most of the
confidence interval we obtained is
through these asymptotic analysis which
simplify a lot of calculation okay so
what we want to do here is also the same
thing is is that possible we can use our
asymptotic analysis to address a lot of
significantly issue in empirical
computational issues okay so this is
reason we put these words together item
topic analysis empirical analysis and
week one these were de-ice empirical
analysis okay so the idea is we want our
theory to inform the practice okay so
this is a very ambitious goal so now let
us take a look at the example so that to
see whether we can do that okay so we
start with these nonparametric models
okay it's a regression setting is very
simple so we have a Univerity response Y
and we have the predictor or features
and we want to do essentially the
regression but different from linear
regression is we have these ada is a non
parametric function we don't know and
then if we assume this random error it's
only is the Gaussian distributed and
this is well known
these are counting process okay these
angle brackets who I try to distinguish
this is the the pate a reservation but
this is the feature first feature until
the B's feature okay and then in
statistics are different from model
fitting we are interested in the
interpreting the results okay so most
desirable results we would like to have
is these so-called analysis of variance
and then parallel to the linear
regression we also have these so-called
functional analysis aware in the
paradigm okay essentially these unknown
function can be decomposed into the
grand mean may effect and two-way
interactions River interaction and so on
and so forth and
after integrated is to to these paradigm
and then we can interpret our is also
like a in linear regression okay way the
model feeding is typically through these
so-called penalize the least worse and
then we have these penalty okay to
characterize the smoothness or roughness
of these non parametric function data
and these lambda is a smoothing
parameter controls the trade-off okay
and typically these minima optimization
is performed you know so called an
reproducing kernel here bro space in
particular because diseases of how the
multiple regression in statistics we
optimize these objective function in
this so called the tensor product
reproducing kernel Hilbert space the
essential idea is very simple is it for
each of these feature okay in its
torment we construct a reproducing
kernel Hilbert space and then we take a
tensor product putting them together who
contracted the bigger reproducing kernel
Hilbert space and they eventually in
these Panther parameter reproducing
kernel Hilbert space these penalty will
equal these weighted summation of a
certain in their products okay this is
essentially a sign I norm in in these in
each of these small reproducing kernel
Hilbert space okay the Troublesome is
here is these theta those are here these
are the ways we also call it as a tuning
parameter okay as we have more and more
predictors and then these number grows
quickly actually exponentially okay so
give you an example for example if we
want to have eight predictors and how
many these say theta tells how we need
to have we roughly with either have 92
of them so these really grows quickly so
mated is the model not very attractive
when you fit this multiple linear
multiple regression
problem okay empirically how we choose
these are lambda and theta okay
empirically there are many of my sir
for example model CL generalized
cross-validation is essentially a
numerical civilized cross-validation in
computer science okay we also have some
more like basing style these so called
restricted in maximum likelihood matter
okay
all these matter the computation is very
intensive is it basically is a in the
sample size cubic are order so it's
really not very practical if you have a
large sample okay so but the only other
hand as I said that in statistical over
the years we have developed tons of
items how the analysis in these field
for example starting from 1980 to
pronounce Superman's first paper we have
a series of paper okay if I summarize
this literature okay
essentially we have these simple results
essentially says okay the so how the
optimal smoothing parameter is
essentially in this order okay in these
other these others so depend on two
things R and P R is related to the order
of functions most function you want okay
typically in this case we use a
smoothing spline to fit the model and
then P is really the underlying true
function how soon is that okay is the
number of observation say you again d
your number feature oh yeah bees and now
that Yi here okay so so you can you can
put D here but it's really not not
nothing in here per se okay so later on
we can we can we can say okay only these
paper explicit they say the D but all
the other paper says you don't need to
consider D okay so these should be good
enough okay and these if you remember in
the studies we also we typically cover
some things of how the route
inconsistency basically says these is a
1/2 okay so but here essentially you
couldn't gather that that order
okay you are slower than that okay so
because this is a nonparametric
regression okay so what what is really
mean this is a capital all other of this
so empirically we can interpret that
these as a constant C times this okay so
now the thing is is this knowledge this
theoretical knowledge can really help us
to trice the computation no easy okay so
what we did here is really very simple
okay our algorithm with presenter is a
simple okay so the easy that comes with
the simple randomized linear algebra so
essentially we just take a subsample
okay of the big sample okay and we
assume these sample size is B okay so
still the theoretical analysis is still
hold and then these this seed we hope
okay is keep as a constant okay and then
this is a full sample theoretical result
and what we did is in this small sample
okay we perform the empirical analysis
using in this particular case we used to
generalize cross-validation to calculate
the empirical smoothing parameter for us
and then we extra plate and then to
gather these okay is this clear yes so
you have a large sample of size n thank
you which you think should dictate this
mini parameter right right but then you
if they calculate there's two hearts
you're doing that a sub sample right but
that should have it that's a different
value n that should yeah these these a
be these sample size oh yeah it's loyal
only this
see that you think is consistent right
we've now made a strong assumption says
see that's now change okay so still the
same see and then once we got our
results we using this small sample we
can calculate this and then we extra
plate we got this thing okay yeah so
this is the whole idea okay so now let's
see how this these are ways or means
simple okay so what are you did is a in
the sub sample you use the empirical
method and then calculate these
smoothing parameter you use that
theoretical formula your extra plate and
the to the full sample and then you got
it okay so because because you already
can see here okay you use use this
divided by this
there's no C anymore because as I said
it's a it's remember this you use this
divided by this and then you know this
you know everything here and then these
will equals this times the D lambda
Delta right I see canceled out in the
ratio right okay okay so anyway so these
these essentially this is the idea
because this is everything is made up
according to the optimal theory so this
theory are automatically holds okay this
is a classical ultimate consistent and
theory for further for the these
nonparametric regression okay
we host not talking about these details
in practice how does that happen ease R
and P P typically you can take a one and
then are you can say that I equals three
but then I for quite different case you
could choose different things okay and
then what we find is our sub sample size
typically equals our core
power of and should be good yes that is
a very good question so what do we find
it because right now we take a simple
random sample that is a uniform assembly
and we find that sometimes it is not
very good so we typically doing several
times what do we find it is five times
easy enough and then we take the meeting
all for these things thing okay and then
T is much less than in there because
these larger than so here with the
assumed is alike the linear regression
which with is that it's a tall matrix so
is that the only it's much much larger
than there's the feature dimension okay
okay so and then we look at the
literature we try to find that is there
any other measure okay so in the
literature actually we Wigley find
something okay
so there is a software manual and the in
this manual they said okay because these
computation is too tough okay they start
with some good starting value and then
you just decided there and then this is
the so called escape and miser okay in
some software or in some our code
okay there is the option say that you
just keep the optimization okay there is
the other method there are some
theoretical statistician he just a
pathway last year called the peterhall
involve he's a theoretical paper he just
said okay like see even or these are
constantly see okay so let's just put it
one here okay we call it as a other
matter and then we compare our matter
with these two miser using this formula
so these essentially this is a means
wherever our food of using these three
measure and these is the measured using
these food sample generalized
cross-validation calculate the mean
square and then we take the ratio and
taken the log okay and we look at the
streets in Orioles
okay
the first scenario we have three
predictors button no interaction okay
how many smoothing parameter we have we
have we only have three and then we look
at another scenario we have three
predictors with two two-way interactions
and then we total have seven smoothing
parameters and in the third case is a
quite large we have eight predictors and
then we look at it 28 to weigh
predictions and two-way interactions and
then we have nightly to smoothing
parameters and then this is the third
scenario okay so the function we use
okay and then we plot these a logarithm
of what I'm I see okay so each of
different color indicating we simulated
data using three using four different
scenarios of different as you know to
noise ratio this signal noise ratio is a
lowest and that is the highest equals
seven okay and then this is our matter
and the Skip matter and other matter and
in this particular case this is setting
one very simple setting and we can see
these other measures does not work very
well okay the other method essentially
just say okay this C equals one let's
fix the number and then using this it
seems a lot of variability okay and work
not as good as this the second scenario
is there are three many facts and the
two-way interactions and in this case we
can see this keep matter begin to work
not as good as our matter and then these
other matters
you have a lot of variability okay and
the third miserly is kind of very
interesting in the sense okay we see you
see these other scheme matter and other
matter does not work very well but
surprisingly all a measured work
extremely well even in a sense it's a
bit at the full sample generalized
cross-validation because it's this is a
disease a zero line okay
so the reason is also understandable in
the sense that because the full sample
is taking a lot of time to calculate and
most of time it didn't converge and then
the program maybe stop there or converge
to some Mesaba optimal okay okay and
then we try these in couple real data
the first day data is a visa beijing PM
2.5 data essentially the response is
these hourly PM 2.5 and then we have
some predictor whether this is taken
either what time and then these dew
point temperatures so and so forth okay
there are six predictors okay and the
total sample size is roughly 40,000 okay
and then in this case we see these model
with nice moving parameters okay and
they eventually we calculate all kind of
these this thing we compare these with a
full sample generalize across wise
decision because these sample size is
not a still it's a doable in the
supercomputer so we can calculate the R
square you can see everything we almost
very close to these full sample
generalize cross radiation score okay
the result but our calculation is much
much faster than using the full sample
calculation okay then the next example
is we apply to the user molecular
dynamics data in these data the sample
size is really huge is almost close to a
million okay we have 36 many facts here
seven two seven two way interactions and
the total number of smoothing parameter
is 57 okay in this case there is no way
we can calculate the sample generalize
cross citation result anymore and so we
can only compare these with this keep my
search because skip measure can set up
the the initial value and then calculate
these results and
in this case we can see okay all our
results is much better than these skip
Messer and also the computation is a
substantial say okay so these is a
pretty much my talk and thank you for
aging what if you just tried like your
your Atlanta saying you just try like
right because typically according to our
experience okay these typically long at
these lambda is typically taken in the
log scale and then in large scale there
are all kind of the different
possibilities and then we typically have
a initial value of sahaba a certain
value but eventually even using
cross-validation eventually it could
converge for any value so it's very hard
to say using grid points that have a
initial range and then using grid point
to do the church yeah that's my
understanding
right practically we use some
essentially some kind of Newton method
plus some bisection whatever to do these
this church yeah that's that's glucan
yeah you need to have some prior
knowledge well for what kind of how
smooth is your underlying function right
P taken between the value of one - okay
why is sort of smooth and the - it's
extremely not they're not very smooth
right so you sort of and it will put
some value there right that could be
[Applause]
using Newton's right yeah but we are
talking about the new the matter is
useful generalize cross-validation is
not a relief to the smoothness is
related to the smoothness our function
by the cross-validation is a different
function than the function is the ADA
function itself
okay yep this is a stupid question since
I don't think I'm over seven o'clock but
to the original Oh and to the lick of
the power that that's an asymptotic
approximation right yeah so even even
for the full sample and so what if the
approximation be even worse for the
subsample beat where because that's an
even smaller that's even further away
from a solution right so you're not
talking about the dawa empirical results
why all a nicer repeat the the the full
sample is that right have even thought
to try that method in the first place
I guess because where you're talking
about applying an asymptotic results of
an even smaller simple daddy's the fall
with the attending the sample and then
we just want to calculate the sample
size is still manageable so we still can
calculate the sample generalize
cross-validation right now is
essentially the code this is the total
standard we want to compare our measure
with gold standard yeah okay did some
more speakers again
[Applause]